Barbie movie what did you learn after
the release did you reflect on sort of
what that did culturally did it do
anything culturally I think it was an
awful lot of conversations around what
true feminist power feminine power means
whether or not there is still this
rampant patriarchy that is kind of
keeping women down the right-wing
reaction and there was the leftwing re
reaction to the right-wing reaction and
all the rest of it I thought it was
interesting my favorite read on the
Barbie movie was that that it was a
straightforwardly reactionary text and
that it was it was arguing fundament
against feminism the embodied
differences between men and women there
was nothing Progressive or feminist
about it at all how so how what would
you say to the people who are like how
could you say this pushing back against
men and men were on the receiving end of
all of the jokes and they laughed at
them and all the rest of the things but
pregnant Barbie was expelled from the
Barby verse I mean there's no darker
commentary on the boundaries of liberal
feminism I mean this is this is what I
spend my entire professional career
Haring on about Chris is the is the fact
that liberal feminism has a mother
shaped blind spot